in this video we're going to discuss
different types of forces but we're
going to do it in the context of free
body diagrams so let's say that i have a
table here and i have a block that is
sitting stationary on that table
what are all of the forces that are
going to act on this block
well to do that to think about that i
can draw a free body diagram where i'm
only going to draw the block remember
when free body diagrams you only care
about the forces acting on one of the
objects in your system so if we're
looking at only the block what's going
on we're going to assume that the block
is on earth we're assuming that it's
stationary well if it's on earth the
block has some weight you have the force
of gravity acting on the block and so
let me draw that in my free body diagram
so you're going to have a downward force
and its magnitude is going to be f sub g
we could also call that or w
and even though this block that contact
with a table which maybe has contact
with the earth weight or the force of
gravity is a long range force even if
this block was in orbit even if it
wasn't in orbit it would still have
gravitational interactions with the
earth the earth would still be pulling
on it but going back to this free body
diagram if this were the only force
acting on the block the block would
accelerate downwards but we're assuming
it's stationary so there must be another
force that is netting out against the
force of gravity
and what would that be
well that would be the force of the
table pushing on the block
and this force of pushing in a direction
that is perpendicular to the surface of
an object that's known as normal force
and its magnitude you could denote as
capital f sub n
let's do another example but this time
instead of having the block on a table
let's say it is hanging from a string
which is attached to the ceiling but
once again everything is stationary draw
a free body diagram for that
well once again i am only concerned with
the block
it's still on earth we're assuming so
you're going to have the force of
gravity acting downwards on the block
but what's keeping it from accelerating
downwards well you might say well you've
got the string that's holding it up that
is pulling on it and that pulling force
is known as tension so what you would
have here is an upward force that nets
out against the force of gravity and
sometimes its magnitude is donated by
capital t
or it might be a
f
sub t
now let's make things a little bit
interesting
let's try to kind of combine these
things and we'll actually introduce a
new force
so let's say that we this is the
ground right over here
i have a block on the ground
and i have a situation where i am
pulling on this block using a rope
with a force of magnitude let's just
call this the force of tension i am
pulling on that block but the block is
not moving what would be the free body
diagram for this block
well i'll do the same thing again i'm
going to draw
the block
now in the vertical direction you have
the same thing that you saw in that
first scenario you're going to have the
force of gravity or the weight of the
block
pulling downward on the block and that's
going to be counteracted by the normal
force of the ground on the block the
ground is holding up the block is one
way to think about it it's keeping it
from accelerating downwards
so the normal force
is acting upwards
but what about the horizontal direction
i already said that i'm pulling to the
right with a force of magnitude f sub t
so let me do that on my free body
diagram
so this would be f
sub t but i said it's stationary so
there must be something that is
counteracting that that is netting
against that going in that direction
what force would that be
well that would be the force of friction
we've all experienced trying to pull on
something try to drag something across
the ground and it doesn't move and
that's because there's friction between
the object and the ground and friction
fundamentally it could be because the
surfaces of the two objects are rough
and you kind of have to grind them past
each other or sometimes it can even be
due to molecular interactions where
they're kind of sticky where the objects
are attracted to each other and you've
got to pull past that
and so in this situation you have the
force of friction counteracting this
pulling force the force of tension
the force of friction and the force of
friction is really interesting because
it always goes against the direction of
sliding it always goes against motion
now with all of these examples out of
the way let's try to do a more complex
scenario
let's say that i have a shelf
and it is it has a weight of
10 newtons
sitting on that shelf
i have an object that has a weight of
five newtons and let's say i have two
wires
and everything is symmetric this weight
is right on the middle and these wires
are both at the ends of the shelf and
this is wire one and this is wire two
and they are attached to the ceiling and
for the sake of simplicity we're going
to assume that the wires have no weight
in actuality they would but for the sake
of this argument let's assume that they
are weightless what would be a free body
diagram for this five newton block that
sits on the shelf
well that one's actually pretty
straightforward and it's analogous to
this first scenario that we saw
you have your block you have the force
of gravity pulling down with a force of
magnitude 5 newtons
and that's going to be counteracted by a
normal force of the same magnitude but
going upwards so let me make sure i have
enough space
so that's going to be counteracted with
the normal force which is going to be
equal to 5 newtons upwards and to be
clear this 5 newtons this is equal to
the weight the magnitude of the weight
of the object so that was pretty
straightforward the free body diagram
for just the block it's really important
to see that because notice in the free
body diagram all you see is the block
but now let's draw the free body diagram
for the shelf
so if i have the shelf right over here
pause this video and try to do that
well we know it's weight it's 10 newtons
so we can do that first so
it has a weight of 10 newtons so the
force the magnitude of the force of
gravity downwards is 10 newtons
is that the only downward force
well no you have this object that's
sitting on it
and gravity is pulling down on that
object with a force of five newtons and
that causes that object to push on our
shelf so that pushing force is actually
a normal force it's due to the gravity
on that five newton object but the end
result is a five newton object is
pushing down on our shelf
so what you have is another force that
is pushing down
it is going to be a five newton force
and really we should view that as a
normal force it's a contact force it's a
pushing force of the 5 newton object on
the 10 newton shelf so this says going
to have a magnitude of 5 newtons
assuming that it's completely stationary
there must be some counteracting forces
here where is that going to come from
well that's going to come from the
pulling forces of these wires
so you're going to have the tension from
rope 1. we could call that t sub 1 and
you're going to have the tension from
wire or rope two t sub two and because
this thing is stationary t sub one plus
t sub two should be equal to ten newtons
plus five newtons
so i'll leave you there we've done a
nice survey of various forces you might
see in a first-year physics class and
we've been able to think about them in
the context of free body diagrams